[Musik]
73 Prozent der Kinder und Jugendlichen
sind noch immer durch Corona psychisch
belastet das sagt ein Bericht von
Familienministerin dieser Pause und
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
Berlin vor der Wahl kommt es in der
Hauptstadt zu einem Wechsel an der
Spitze ja das und vieles mehr das
Besprechen ich jetzt hier bei 8:15 Uhr
mit diesem gestern Marcel Luthe dem Mann
der bis zum Verfassungsgerichtshof zog
und die Wiederholung der pannenball
durchgesetzt hat wir müssen die
Demokratie stärken sagt er heute und
waren vor der Radikalisierung an den
Rändern Psychiater und Bestseller Autor
Rafael Bonelli macht sich ebenfalls
Sorgen um die Gesellschaft und spricht
vom narzisstischen Moralismus der sich
zunehmend breit machte was er darunter
genau versteht das erklärt uns hier
Ökonomen und Existenz Markus Krall
kritisiert die nach seiner Meinung
aufgeblähten Sozialstaat und fordert
eine Rückkehr zu mehr Eigenverantwortung
der Bürger sie werden es aus eigener
Kraft geschafft und das heute
deutschlands berühmtester reality star
was ich manche sehr einfach vorstellen
es sei aber harte Arbeit sagt Kader Loth
er Lockdown lange Schulschließungen
gesperrte Spielplätze und Partys nur
noch virtuell das hat Deutschlands
Kinder und Jugendlichen schwer zugesetzt
Familienministerin Lisa
pausengesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach haben dazu eine
Studienauftrag gegeben die Ergebnisse
sind erschütternd 73 Prozent der Kinder
und Jugendlichen sind schwer psychisch
angeschlagen viele brauchen
professionelle Hilfe Psychiater
berichten sogar von Suizidgedanken bei
unter zehnjährigen droht uns da eine auf
Dauer Geschädigte Generation hätte man
das verhindern können Herr Bonelli sie
sind bei uns vielleicht können Sie uns
einmal mitnehmen in den Alltag den sie
erleben als Psychiater in ihrer Praxis
was hat sich da verändert kommen zu
Ihnen Eltern die genau solche Themen
solche Sorgen um ihre Kinder haben
also ich habe ich habe Patienten mit den
verschiedensten Problemen und natürlich
hat Corona irgendwie das Klientel
verändert und zwar besonders leiden
Menschen glaube ich vor allem unter der
Spaltung der Gesellschaft also wie wir
miteinander umgehen also da ist wirklich
spürbar dass ich deine Veränderung
hergestellt hat also Menschen die nie in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft waren und
plötzlich Diskriminierung ausgegrenzt
wurden die Erfahrungen gemacht haben die
man eigentlich normalerweise nicht macht
oder die ich nur wirklich von sehr
speziellen Gruppen kenne also
Migrationshintergrund Juden zum Beispiel
ich habe sehr viele oder homosexuelle
Menschen die das kennen ausgegrenzt zu
werden plötzlich sind das Gruppen die
ganz anders sind also die die mitten in
der mitten in der Gesellschaft war also
das spürt man und wenn ich das jetzt
hört von den Kindern dann denke ich man
hat natürlich auch mit den Erwachsenen
zu tun ja weil viele Eltern waren extrem
überfordert dass ihre Kinder plötzlich
zu Hause sind die waren nervös die waren
aggressiv und das hat natürlich auf die
Kinder dann auch zurückgewirkt werden
allein dass ein Kind nicht in die Schule
gehen darf macht es noch nicht das Kind
depressiv sondern die Frage ist was
erlebt es dann zu Hause
Suizidgedanken bei Kindern ich muss
sagen wenn ich mir sowas alleine zu
hören bricht mir das Herz das kann doch
nicht sein dass das jetzt die Folge ist
73 Prozent der Kinder und Jugendlichen
das ist so eine große Mehrheit die
psychisch leiden was glauben Sie was
waren die schrecklichsten Maßnahmen die
Maßnahmen die besonders große psychische
Schäden bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
hinterlassen für mich ist Psychiater war
die Maske ganz besonders dramatisch weil
sie die Kommunikation zwischen den
Menschen vor unmöglich hat und besonders
die Kinder brauchen ein ein
fürsorgliches gegenüber und wenn das
dann nur noch eine Maske ist die
vielleicht auch noch Angst hat und die
vielleicht von den Kindern weggrenzt die
die Kinder vielleicht das pestraten
beschimpft oder sowas dann glaube ich
ist klar dass diese Kinder gestört
werden gestört in ihrem Entwicklung also
das nehme ich schon ganz klar waren was
kann man tun um zu helfen was raten Sie
hier auch Eltern man kann vielleicht
auch viele Ängste erst mal gar nicht
einordnen oder versucht die erstmal zu
überspielen hauptsache man macht das
Kind wieder glücklich was raten sie
Eltern die sich da in besonderer Sorge
befinden die Frage ist richtig gestellt
weil wenn ein Kind ein Problem hat dann
ist das meistens ein systemisches
Problem das heißt es hat mit den Eltern
zu tun hat mit den Geschwistern zu tun
und man musste also wenn man von außen
ist Therapeut kommt muss man schauen
dass wieder Ruhe ins System kommt das
wieder ein Frieden herrscht weil auch
innerhalb der Familien kann es ja zu
diesen Spaltungen zu diesen
Verurteilungen ich habe immer wieder mit
Patienten geredet die gesagt haben ich
werde von der Großfamilie nicht
eingeladen weil ich nicht umgeimpft bin
zum Beispiel solche Sachen das müssen
wir es auch arbeiten dann muss es
versöhnen geben da muss man sich da muss
man sich auch entschuldigen solche
Sachen müssen passieren und den Kindern
gegenüber muss man müssen die Eltern
glaube ich für Frieden sorgen also
gerade wenn die Eltern miteinander im
Streit liegen dann leiden die Kinder
meisten und hier ist viel zu tun
viel zu tun viele Fehler die man auch
einfach gar nicht mehr ungeschehen
machen kann frau Loth viele Menschen
haben gelitten auch ältere die dann
einsam und alleine in Heimen sterben
mussten keine Familienmitglieder dürften
mehr zu ihnen bisher haben sie in dieser
Zeit gelitten also es ist ja so ich habe
meine Eltern paar Monate lang nicht
gesehen ja und weil ich aufgrund weil
ich einen schweren Verlauf hatte und
mit Lungenentzündung sie haben alles
mitbekommen und es ist ja jetzt so dass
meine Eltern ich bin zweimal die Woche
da ich mache deren Einkäufe die geht
immer noch nicht raus alleine sind über
80 Jahre sind Risiko Patienten und meine
beiden Brüder glauben nicht an Corona
und da gibt's immer wieder
aufeinandertreffen Probleme Streit ich
habe den Hausverbot gegeben die dürfen
meine Eltern nicht besuchen weil ich
gesagt habe ihr habt Zutritt in die
Wohnung wenn die die Masken trägt oder
wenn ihr einen frischen
Corona testen macht ja meine Eltern
waren schon zweimal an Corona erkrankt
hatten auch Gott sei Dank haben sie
überlebt aber ich möchte kein Risiko
mehr eingehen weil irgendjemand
abergläubig ist nicht an Corona glaubt
diese diese
Krankheit ist nicht mit einer normalen
Grippe zu vergleichen verdammt ich bin
selber erkrankt ich wusste gar nicht ob
ich noch am Leben bleibe so schlimm ging
es mir ich hatte auch seelische
psychische wirklich Probleme Schmerzen
danach das hat sich bis drei vier bis
ein halbes Jahr hat sich das angehalten
ne und keiner kann sich in die Lage
versetzen von einem Menschen der einen
schweren Verlauf hatte und ich bin echt
müde müde davor geworden immer wieder
aufs Neue Menschen zu erklären Leute es
gibt Corona und da habe ich auch
natürlich einige Freunde verloren auf
die ich auch gerne heute verzichte und
auch mit meinem Brüdern spreche ich
nicht mehr weil die denken ich würde
übertreiben die haben mir noch bis jetzt
keine Corona gehabt ich habe gesagt okay
dann werden wir uns vielleicht einmal
oder zweimal im Jahr treffen ich nehme
das in Kauf Hauptsache meine Eltern
leben vielleicht noch paar Jahre und
dann sind sie tot aber wie lange wollen
Sie das aufrecht erhalten also bis zum
Tod
bis zum Schluss bin ich radikal geworden
weil wer nicht das respektiert das
ältere Menschen riesige gefährdeter sind
als junge Leute der muss einfach gerade
meine Geschwister ich habe immer wieder
Soft- und Streit und manchmal spreche
ich mit dem bitte nur mit Maske die
Eltern besuchen und so ich lege einfach
den Hörer auf ich habe einfach satt
immer mich zurechtfertigen und zu
erklären es ist nicht mit einer Grippe
zu vergleichen verdammt Herr Bonelli
genau das sind ja auch sehr interessiert
diese diese Risse die durch
Freundschaften die durch Familien gehen
die sind da
und haben sie eine Empfehlung wie kann
man überhaupt diese Risse wie sehr
leiden in ihrer Eltern auch meine Eltern
leiden sehr ich leider auch sehr aber
dann frage ich mich wenn Menschen jemand
Menschen besuchen und auch lieben das
sind auch die Eltern ne von von von
Geschwistern dann müssen Sie einfach mal
verdammt in der Lage sein für eine
Stunde die Maske aufzusetzen
verhärtet wie kann man verteilen also
das kann man heilen indem man alle auf
einen Tisch bringt oder indem man eben
versucht sich gegenseitig Wert zu
schätzen und seine eigene Meinung auch
ein bisschen zu relativieren und
aufeinander zu hören hier ist natürlich
wichtig was wollen Eltern also ich
erlebe relativ ich erlebe relativ häufig
dass
ältere Menschen abgeschirmt werden von
einem von einer von einem Kind und die
anderen Kinder eigen und die leiden
darunter dass die anderen Kinder nicht
dort sein dürfen weil sie Regeln
aufstellen und glaube ich da muss man
schon einen Kompromiss finden Beispiele
einer meiner Patientin hat ein Kind
bekommen aber
ein Teil der Familie hat ihr verboten
das Kind der Urgroßmutter sozusagen 95
die wollte das Kind sehen aber es hat
sich halt jemand dazwischen sozusagen
zwischen zwischen
ist 95
das Kind war ihr der wichtiger als dass
sie noch ein paar Wochen lebt sie wollte
noch ihren Urenkel sehen
wir jetzt hier auch in diesem Beispiel
durch Familien durch die Gesellschaft
durch Freundschaften Herr lute was sie
haben Kinder sind sie denn besser durch
diese Krise durchgekommen ich selbst
oder die Kinder alle gemeinsam als
Familie was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
willst du auch noch mal in dieser Zahl
festhalten weil die 73% finde ich
schockierend wenn ich denke dass es
unseren Kindern und Jugendlichen so geht
wir haben in der Tat anfangs sehr viel
damit zu tun gehabt narrativen zu
begegnen die da verbreitet worden ja
also dieses wenn du hustest bringst du
die Oma um ja das waren ja Sachen die
tatsächlich Kindern von Personen von
denen sie eigentlich gelernt haben dass
man den vertrauen soll dass sie
informiert sind dass sie eine
wahrheitsgemäße Informationen
übermitteln
zum Beispiel alle Schulen Vergleiche mit
Ratten etc dramatische dramatische Dinge
die dort mit den Seelen der Kinder
geschehen sind
den man Verantwortung das ist nach wie
vor es ist schlichtweg lächerlich zu
sagen ja von dem oder dem habe ich mich
da oder da angesteckt das ist
bekanntermaßen das brauchen wir
wissenschaftlich nicht drüber reden
vollkommener Unfug es steht auf einem
Virus nicht drauf wo sie das hier haben
ja vollkommener Quatsch trotzdem wurde
ein solcher Schuldkult damit betrieben
und das hat Kinder massiv belastet weil
sie eben halt auch nicht mehr frei
miteinander interagieren konnten und
weil sie sich eben halt in der Tat
gefragt haben Mensch der oder der ist
jetzt krank bin ich vielleicht auch noch
Schuld ja und jetzt stellen wir uns noch
mal vor die 95-Jährige Großmutter oder
Urgroßmutter wäre dann verstorben und er
fragt sich das Kind trage ich daran
Schuld nein selbstverständlich nicht
aber es ist in einem bemerkenswerten
massenpsychologischen Phänomen von allen
Seiten diesen Kindern eingeredet worden
also die Schäden finde ich in der Tat
Dates wir haben eben halt tatsächlich
bei uns zumindest die Möglichkeit gehabt
rational über die Dinge zu reden hör zu
erklären wo besteht was besteht welche
Gefahr das beispielsweise eben in der
Tat eine Vergleichbarkeit mit dem
Grippevirus versterblichkeit angeht
herrscht wissen wir mittlerweile da sind
anfangs ich habe das ja im
Abgeordnetenhaus damals in Debatten
unmittelbar miterlebt war von der
Sterblichkeit von zwischen 10 und 15
Prozent gesprochen das war übrigens auch
der Moment in dem ich im März 2020
gesagt hätte vielleicht sind es Masken
gar keine schlechte Idee mit dem Stand
den man damals hatte einen Monat später
zwei Monate später drei Monate später
hatte man schon ganz andere Erkenntnisse
erst recht ein Jahr später und wir haben
bis viel zu lange durchgezogen haben in
der Generation von Kindern belastet die
nicht ungezwungen miteinander aufwachsen
konnten die teilweise gar nicht gelernt
haben sich eben halt auch im
Schulunterricht miteinander
auszutauschen weil das ja auch lange
virtuell stattfand und die jetzt erst
mühsam und im übrigen mit dem
geschwächten Immunsystem wird das Masken
tragen weil sie eben halt gar keine
Abwehrreaktion entwickeln konnten jetzt
neu in Krankheiten reinlaufen wir haben
massiv dort eingegriffen dass ich Gott
sei Dank muss mir das nicht vorwerfen
aber es ist jetzt dringend an der Seite
bin ich völlig bei ihnen darüber zu
sprechen wie man eine
Schließung dieses Risses wieder
hinbekommen kann aber nicht mit einem
Schwamm drüber konnte man nicht wissen
wie jetzt einige Leute sagen sondern in
der Tat wenn ich darüber nachgedacht
hätte hätte ich es wissen sollen es darf
sich nicht noch einmal wiederholen der
Staat ist dafür verantwortlich Lockdown
die Schulschließungen muss jetzt der
Staat auch die Mittel zur Verfügung
stellen den Kindern zu helfen also der
Staat hat es verbockt und der Staat wird
nicht reparieren ich sag's mal so hart
und ich glaube dass die ganze Misere
über die wir da sprechen die hat mit dem
Staat insofern was zu tun als die wie
soll ich sagen dieses ständige betiteln
unseres ganzen Lebens durch den Staat
die hat dazu geführt dass die Menschen
mit Risiken nicht mehr vernünftig
umgehen können und auch wenn ich
niemandem in seine eigenen Erfahrung zu
nahe treten möchte so ist es ein
riesiger Unterschied ob man ein Risiko
an der eigenen Erfahrung fest macht oder
ob es tatsächlich wissenschaftlich mit
anderen Worten statistisch unterlegt ist
und es gibt auch bei Grippe schwere
Verläufe die gibt's man stirbt auch an
Grippe in der unter bestimmten Umständen
also alte Leute sterben Krippe und es
gab in der Vergangenheit auch immer
Grippewellen ohne dass wir wie soll ich
sagen die Gesellschaft an den Rand des
Zusammenbruchs geführt hätten aber wir
haben uns daran gewöhnt dass sämtliche
Risiken die wir wahrnehmen vom Staat uns
abgenommen werden gemanagt werden vom
Staat und wenn dann der Staat in seiner
sag mal Machtvollkommenheit und
Übergriffigkeit und zum Teil auch Hybris
ein Risiko komplett falsch einschätzt
oder wenn er dazu getrieben wird ein
Risiko komplett falsch einzuschätzen
dann ist es Ergebnis dass die Menschen
dem nachrennen dem Glauben weil sie ja
quasi ihre risikofverantwortlichkeit
seit Jahren an den Staat delegiert haben
und so funktioniert's aber nicht wir
müssen endlich mal wieder lernen selbst
Risiken einzuschätzen und wenn wir ein
Fehler gemacht haben und das war ein
Fehler und wir haben an dieser Stelle
als Gesellschaft überhaupt nicht
evidenzbasiert gehandelt denn im Grunde
genommen war schon seit Frühjahr 2020
klar dass die Sterblichkeit nicht so
sind wie man es erstmal befürchtet hatte
übrigens interessant an der Stelle wenn
man sich im April 2020
sterblichkeitsquoten der einzelnen
europäischen Länder angeschaut hat und
die man miteinander verglichen hat aber
festgestellt dass die von 0,02 Prozent
bis 13 Prozent in die Systeme
reingemeldet haben also eine riesige
Spannweite und interessant auch dass die
Sterblichkeit die gemeldet wird umso
höher war je höher die
Staatsverschuldung eines Landes war also
die Länder mit der höchsten
Staatsverschuldung haben die höchste
Sterblichkeit angeblich gehabt kann man
nachrechnen wenn man in die Statistiken
und vor allem auch bei meiner Frage wer
soll jetzt helfen wenn sie sagen der
Staat kann es nicht regeln was können
wir tun damit diese Kinder
73%, die mit psychischen Folgen zu
kämpfen haben weil sie nicht in die
Schule gehen dürften weil sie keinen
Kontakt zu Freunden hatten weil nicht
weil der Spielplatz offen war weil sie
zu Hause saßen und kein Kontakt Schule
ist ein soziales Gefüge nicht nur zum
Lernen und jetzt darunter liegen wir
haben es falsch gemacht erwachsen hin
oder her und es darf nicht wieder
passieren
also ich bin kein Psychologe ich kann
nicht einschätzen wie Psychologen da
helfen können das weiß der Bonelli
sicher besser als ich aber ich glaube in
aller erster Linie mal müssen wir wieder
zu einem familiären zusammen sein
zurückfinden dass das allerwichtigste
und deswegen glaube ich dass jede jeder
Gedanke erstmal darauf ausgerichtet sein
sollte wie man den familiären
Zusammenhang Zusammenhalt wieder stärkt
und alles was das stört gehört
eigentlich weg und dann muss ich Ihnen
auch ehrlich sagen da verstehe ich ihre
Haltung nicht für absolutieren Sie nicht
Ihre eigene Erfahrung sondern was sagt
die Wissenschaft die Wissenschaft sagt
wir haben eine Sterblichkeit die
vergleichbar ist mit der Grippe und ja
auch Grippe kann schlimm sein und ja wir
haben alle Ängste und ja wir versuchen
alle mit riesigen umzugehen aber wir
sollten es wieder rational machen
brauchen wir mehr Psychologen musste
Starter auch mehr Geld zur Verfügung
stellen man hat warte listen hier in
Deutschland sie haben heißt es in
Österreich aber man kriegt nicht so
schnell einen Therapeuten der helfen
kann
nämlich ganz wichtig die
angstkommunikation wenn ein erlebt dass
die dass das alle Angst haben
fürchterlich Angst haben dann dann
überträgt sich das auf das Kind nicht
also wir wissen das von den Helikopter
Müttern und Helikopter Vätern dass die
eine Angst in das Kind produzieren dass
das Kind glaubt alles ist gefährlich und
genauso war Corona in Corona hatten die
Erwachsenen so viel Angst und haben die
Kinder so stark eingeschränkt dass die
Kinder zu leiden begonnen haben also das
ist glaube ich das erste und das zweite
ist dass sie vom sozialen Leben
weggeschnitten wurden hin zum virtuellen
Leben weil natürlich der Internetkonsum
und der computerkonsum ist halt extrem
gewachsen und ich habe Kinder in der
Praxis oder Erzählungen von Eltern ich
bin Erwachsenen Psychiater dass die
Kinder eigentlich von dem Apparat gar
nicht mehr wegkommen und auch nicht mehr
wollen und sich auch nicht mehr
interessieren für reale Freunde oder
ihre Freunde sind jetzt virtuell also
ich glaube da ist ein riesiger Schaden
und da müssen wir da müssen wir
hinschauen wenn sie jetzt sagen
flächendeckend Psychologen ja ich meine
ich wohne halt jetzt in Wien mit der
höchsten Psychotherapeuten Dichte in auf
der ganzen Welt würde ich mal sagen
aber und ich finde man kann es auch
übertreiben also wichtig ist dass wir
ein Umfeld schaffen wo wir wo wo wo
normale Familie sich normal entwickeln
kann glaube ich das ist wesentlich und
und nicht das alles sofort Therapeut
therapiert wird weil wir weil wir
produzieren sonst Patienten es gibt ja
schon eben auch
psychotherapiegeschädigte nicht die die
aus dieser aus diesem aus dieser Nummer
der Psychotherapie gar nicht rauskommen
ich will es nicht gegen meinen Fach
sprechen aber man kann es auch
übertreiben nicht deswegen ich glaube
wir brauchen ganz viel Normalität und
die hat gefehlt in den letzten drei
Jahren Normalität hat gesehen auch vor
Corona bereits viele Probleme Probleme
definitiv die Menschen auch hatten
bereits vor der Pandemie sie haben
darüber auch Bücher geschrieben und sie
sagen immer mehr Menschen würden einem
moralischen Narzissmus verfallen was ist
genau ist und welche Gefahr davon davon
ausgeht das erklären Sie uns bitte jetzt
also moralischen Narzissmus ist ein
Begriff den ich entwickelt habe weil
Narzissmus sehr bekannt ist aber dieses
dieses Phänomen des Narzissmus nämlich
dass man sich selbst idealisiert das
heißt ich bin der beste und zweitens
einmal den anderen abwerte dass es du
bist nichts wert also diese zwei
Parameter sind wichtig und das dritte
ist die selbst immer nein im Vergleich
zur Selbsttranszendenz das heißt ich
erkenne nichts Höheres an außer mich
selbst ja das ist der Narzissmus mal
prinzipiell das sind die Kriterien
findet
psychische Störung aber man kann von mir
aus sagen es ist eine Krankheit aber man
kann auch sagen es ist eine Charakter
fehlt ja also je nachdem weil das ist
auch ein Bösewicht aber das Problem ist
jetzt dass diese dass diese Haltung wird
immer häufiger besonders in der Politik
und das ist jetzt gekippt ins moralische
hinein das heißt Menschen beginnen sich
besser zu fühlen weil sie der Meinung
sind dass Ihre
Meinung nicht nur richtig ist sondern
auch gut ist also und die einzig Gute
und das Gegenüber hat eine böse Meinung
das heißt das heißt Menschen schlittern
durch die moralischen Narzissmus in die
vollkommene Intoleranz nicht nur eine
Intoleranz sondern eben auch in die
cancel culture das heißt in die in die
soziale Vernichtung des anderen ich bin
wirklich überrascht wie viele
Referenten schon gecancelt werden
harmlose Menschen die plötzlich in ihrer
Halle diese gebucht haben ausgeladen
werden es die Ausladungen die
expandieren jetzt diese dieser Fall von
dieser Biologin nicht ausgeladen wurde
weil dann auch viele weil dann auch
viele Leute umkippen aber die Aggression
ist eine logische Folge des moralischen
Narzissmus der moralischen Narzisst
glaube dass er besser ist es der Rest
und dass sie sich alles erlauben kann
und was beim Narzissten so typisch ist
dass die goldene Regel für ihn nicht
gilt die goldene Regel lautet was du
nicht willst dass man dir tut das füge
auch einem anderen zu dann Narzisst sagt
ihr müsst gut zu mir sein aber ich bin
nicht gut zu euch weil ich bin besser
und genau das ist mal reich und
Narzissmus und das kann man festmachen
zum Beispiel bei den Klima Klebern das
also man ordnet alles dem guten
moralischen Ziel unter und das mal ganz
plakativ zu sagen oder machen man
definiert das was man denkt dass
moralisch gut die orientieren sich nicht
nach dem Objektiv moralisch guten sind
nicht bereit ihre ihre Haltung zu
korrigieren an einem Objektiv guten
sondern sie sagen das was ich sage ist
gut und immer das ist gut was ihnen
keine Anstrengung verursachen also wenn
einer kein Geld hat dann findet es gut
wenn die Reichen Geld hergeben wenn er
aber viel Geld hat dann ist er nicht
mehr dafür dass die Reichen Geld
hergeben nicht also das ist moralischer
Narzissmus nee Menschen die anfälliger
sind als andere für dieses Phänomen
für den moralischen Narzissmus also
ehrlich gesagt Narzissmus ist jedem oder
genau Narzissmus steckt prinzipiell in
jedem Menschen aber die Frage ist bin
ich bereit dagegen zu kämpfen bin ich
bereit das
für ein ein gedeihliches Miteinander
abzudrücken runter zu drücken und dem
anderen respektvoll zu behandeln oder
gehe ich mit Ellbogen durchs Leben nicht
und das ist eine innere Frage also eine
innere Entscheidung die man trifft und
und trifft dann die Entscheidung dass
man sagt okay meine Weltanschauung ist
wichtig und alle anderen nicht ich bin
wirklich erschrocken wie ich meine ich
bin jetzt schon einige Jahre auf der
Welt aber wie in den letzten paar Jahren
man merkt dass die Parteien viele
Parteien nicht mehr miteinander sprechen
können wenn man sagt mit dir spreche ich
nicht mehr also das ich weiß nicht wie
ich jung war das nicht gegeben weil wir
sind in die Wiener Kaffeehäuser gesessen
wir haben mit Kommunisten geredet mit
national oder gibts nicht aber rechten
mit was auch immer wir haben mit allem
geredet wir haben diskutiert wir haben
heftig ist die poliert aber heute ist ja
die kontaktschulter das heißt wenn du
mit so jemanden redest wenn du ein
Interview an das falsche Magazin machst
dann ist egal was du gesagt hast es ist
ja schon eine Schuld dass du Themen
Interview gegeben hast und das ist krank
Frau sie schütteln auch ein bisschen den
Kopf also sie stimmt nicht ganz einer da
gibt es Menschen nur sie sagen mit denen
möchte ich einfach nicht sprechen ja es
gibt Menschen die Egomanen sind
natürlich die an sich denken aber so
krankhafte Narzissen mit Narzissten habe
ich Gott sei Dank nichts zu tun gehabt
das findet in jeder menschliche
Beziehung statt natürlich ne das kann
zwischen Mann und Frau sowas nicht
abspielen ne in einer Beziehung aber
kann man auch von einer normalen
Narzissmus sprechen weil sie gerade
gesagt haben jeder Mensch besitzt eine
gewisse Narzissmus aber es gibt keinen
guten Narzissmus also Narzissmus ist
immer schlecht weil er sich über die
anderen stellt also je mehr
narzisstische Anteile ein Mensch hat
umso problematischer wird vor allem für
die Umgebung aber am Ende Ende da auch
allein haben wir verlernt Herr lute dass
wir alle miteinander reden haben wir
verlernt dass wir in der offene
Diskussion geben gehen also es stellen
Sie dieses Phänomen auf fest also ich
habe das im Abgeordnetenhaus hier
deutlich gemacht in den vergangenen
Jahren da also für mich war es ganz
normal jedem Kollegen die anzugeben bei
einer Ausschusssitzung erstmal ja und
Hinsetzen sprechen für mich war es auch
normal mit jedem Kollegen ihr von der
ehemaligen SED bis hin zur AFD im
Gespräch zu führen auch die damals aus
der AFD ausgeschlossen bzw ausgetreten
Kollegen weil ich sage wir müssen
wenigstens wir als Abgeordnete wenn
schon die gesellschaftlichen Gruppen die
wir vertreten nicht miteinander reden
können weil sie es irgendwie verlernt
haben weil sie dann Aggression haben
wenigstens wir haben dann die Aufgabe in
einem demokratischen Rahmen miteinander
ins Gespräch zu kommen und zumindest das
zu machen was ja ist demokratischen
Diskurse es ist dem anderen zuzuhören
seine Meinung zu erwägen und dann auf
dieser Grundlage meiner eigenen
Entscheidung zu treffen die kann ja auch
durchaus sein ich teile nichts von dem
was sie gerade gesagt haben aber
zumindest höre ich es mir einmal an und
dann bin ich dran doch auch noch mal was
und hört sich das auch an das muss
nichts verändern aber es trägt zumindest
eben zu dem bei was Demokratie ausmacht
Demokratie funktioniert nur wenn
Menschen miteinander reden ansonsten
kommen Sie in eine Form ich nenne es mal
demokratieur das heißt wir haben jetzt
mit 50,1% das beschlossen und das müssen
jetzt alle mitmachen so funktioniert es
eben halt genau nicht in einer
Demokratie stimmen Sie dazu ist das
etwas was viel zu selten geworden ist
dass man viel mehr in den Diskurs
vielleicht auch mal in einen Streit geht
aber Hauptsache man setzt sich mal mit
Themen auseinander absolut dem stimmig
100% zu ich glaube was gerade gesagt hat
das Thema Bequemlichkeit das kann man an
der Stelle nicht überschätzen und zwar
einfach deswegen weil die Bequemlichkeit
verführt die Menschen dazu den Diskurs
aus dem Wege zu gehen erst geht mir aus
dem Wege dann verweigert man sich ihm
und wenn man sich ihm in der
gesellschaftlichen Auseinandersetzung
nicht mehr entziehen kann dann versucht
man den Diskurs dadurch abzutöten dass
man ab Personen geht das heißt also man
muss sich nicht mehr mit dem Argument
auseinandersetzen wenn man den anderen
wenn man dem anderen irgendein
gesellschaftlich unakzeptables Etikett
ankleben kann das ist der Grund für im
Prinzip dieses Seuche dass man alle als
linksradikal rechtsradikal oder sonst
als was weiß ich alles beschimpft wenn
ich erstmal die Person quasi als guter
Mensch quasi unmöglich gemacht habe dann
muss ich mich ja nicht mehr mit ihm
auseinandersetzen und diese Sache hat
leider im politischen Leben in den
letzten Jahren viel zu viel Erfolg
gehabt und sie hat dadurch immer mehr
Teilnehmer an dem ganzen Gebilde dazu
erzogen sich erstens sind ihre Blase
zurückzuziehen und zweitens selber
diesen hat persona dieses Personen am
Thema einzuüben weil wenn ich mich jetzt
noch mit den Argumenten des anderen
auseinandersetzen muss ja da muss ja
noch nachdenken da muss ich mich noch
anstrengen das geht gar nicht also diese
Art die Tüte die müssen wir eigentlich
mal bekämpfen und die findet
auf allen Spektren des politischen Stadt
sie ist zwar am besten nach meiner
Überzeugung eingeübt auf dem linken
Spektrum weil die haben einfach mehr
Erfahrung aber es ist nicht so dass die
dann Monopol drauf hätten ist das denn
sie haben jetzt diesen Begriff geprägt
ist es zumindest für sie in irgendeiner
Form heilbar oder lassen Sie uns
zumindest mal nach vorne schauen was
brauchen wir damit sich das nicht
durchsetzt also was ich noch nachtragen
wollte ist besonders toxisches System
und das ist narzisstisch da dann
Narzisst sagt wie kannst du nur so böse
sein wo ich doch so gut bin das ist die
Empörung nicht und diese dieses laute
sich empören also dass das ist das ist
zum guten Ton geworden also wer sie
nicht den Börse gehört eben nicht zu den
besseren Menschen oder zu den
moralischen Narzissten halt ich sag's
halt so ne
und wie heilen wir das ich glaube in dem
immer mehr Menschen draufkommen
moralische Narzissmus ist nicht gut also
dass sich über die anderen erheben ist
nicht gut also meine Meinung ist die
einzig richtige ich habe die Weisheit
mit dem Löffel gefressen und niemand
anderer hat hier was zu sagen ich weiß
was lang geht das nehme ich erst in den
letzten drei bis fünf Jahren
Bequemlichkeit war auch das Thema also
zum einen Narzissmus von anderen haben
wir hier gehört eine gewisse
Bequemlichkeit Frau und dass man sagt
man kämpft jetzt nicht mehr
beispielsweise um Freundschaften wo man
vielleicht nicht einer Meinung ist wenn
man Dinge anders sieht wo man vielleicht
beim Thema Corona komplett andere
Standpunkte hat das Gefühl wir sind da
zu faul geworden um zu kämpfen sagen
sehr gut dann halt nicht dann kommt
nicht aber wenn man ein paar mal schon
drüber versucht hat zu sprechen gute
Gespräche zu führen man ist müde
geworden ich bin einfach müde geworden
weil ich einfach immer wieder auch
irgendwo die Kraft auftreiben muss immer
wieder den Menschen einfach mal sagen
mit denen ich ob das Freunde sind oder
Familien Angehörige weil da kommt kein
Entgegenkommen auf mich zu und das war
so dass man sich in der Mitte treffen
kann aber muss man sich unbedingt
einigen ist das quasi nur möglich wenn
man dann gemeinsamen Punkt aber es kommt
immer auf die Person drauf an wenn es
Freunde sind dann sage ich okay tschüss
wir sehen uns nie wieder sollte Freunde
brauche ich nicht weil Freundschaft ist
für mich jemand auf Augenhöhe ja und
wenn es um Familienmitglieder geht das
geht schon unter die Haut also das ist
schon manchmal auch schmerzvoll
eskaliert manchmal bei den Gesprächen
man wiederholt sich immer wieder und
besser sage ich immer ich gehe den
Leuten aus dem Weg dann spart man sich
einiges an diesen Standpunkt bin ich
momentan waren sie bereit sich in der
Mitte zu treffen mit ihrem Brüdern was
die Eltern aber nicht ja aber wir können
Sie Ihrem Brüdern verbieten dass die
Brüder ihre Eltern das ist natürlich ein
bisschen extrem ausgedrückt also
verbieten nicht aber ich habe gesagt
lass uns in der Mitte treffen ihr dürft
die Eltern besuchen aber bitte nur mit
Maske wenn
ja das ist ja ihre Welt
die Gesundheit meiner Eltern aber das
ist ein trotzdem ein Übergriff weil es
geht um die Beziehung zwischen ihren
Eltern ihren Eltern und ihren Brüdern
das geht zehn Prinzip nichts an außer
sie sind davor und ihre Eltern das sind
sie aber glaube ich nicht also wir sehen
da ist fast eine Tochter ich um die
Eltern also ich habe das
ja aber die sind ja für die Eltern
wirklich nicht da die also die kommen
einfach nur so vorbei ich mache die
Einkäufe ich war die zu den Arztterminen
ich gehe mit dem spazieren ich verstehe
den Eltern ich bin aber da ist da ein
Thema also Straßenmusik in einer
Therapiestunde fast alleine lassen weil
ich glaube der kann man wahrscheinlich
mit ihrer Hilfe wir haben gerade gesagt
es muss nicht immer in Therapeut im
Psychiater kommen aber vielleicht kann
man da auch in der Familie Blut noch mal
ein bisschen lernen
sich sterben können Kontakt mit uns
sehen
also eine gesunde Pflicht gegenüber den
Eltern dass man einfach die Fürsorge
übernimmt dass sie einfach wieder nicht
in die Lage kommen
wichtig dass Sie das machen aber ich
weiß nicht ob es klug ist wenn sie ihren
Brüdern vorschreiben wie sie die Eltern
wahrscheinlich hier jetzt nicht auflösen
können aber ich glaube das ist ein ganz
ganz genau das Prinzip
selbst relativieren
als die beiden Eltern an Corona erkrankt
sind war keiner da ich habe Arzt gerufen
ich habe gekocht für Sie ich habe mich
um alles gekümmert wir sind einfach
Bewusstsein bin ich geworden dass wenn
es brennt ist keiner da die Hüte brennt
ab ich bin die Ansprechpartner deshalb
sage ich den Leuten also ihr wart nicht
da also ihr könnt auch keinen ich stelle
hier die Prioritäten wenn ihr die Eltern
wenn es dem wichtigsten
Stunden bei meiner Eltern wenn ich die
Besuche warum können
Sendung über dieses Thema noch mal unter
direkt in ihr Zimmer rein das können sie
glaube ich jetzt nicht auflösen wir
treffen Punkt einmal möchte ich bitte in
Ihr Thema reingehen gerade nämlich
gesagt sie sind müde geworden und ich
kann mir vorstellen ich sehe sie beide
haben Diskussionsbedarf ich glaube aber
der ist so groß geworden
sie sind müde geworden und sie sind auch
müde geworden ihren Job sozusagen zu
verteidigen sie sind einer der größten
reality Stars die wir hier in
Deutschland haben und man sagt
vielleicht ja die macht er so ein
bisschen Fernsehen ein bisschen
Instagram haha und sie sagen aber da
steckt sehr sehr viel mehr arbeitet
dahinter als ganz viele womöglich
glauben das ist ihr richtig es ist ja so
ich bin ja mit der Mitte seit der ersten
Stunde der reality dabei ist sie
wahrscheinlich sind alle Akademiker ich
gehe davon aus und sie kennen die
reality TV-Landschaft nicht
gucken sich die Sommerhaus an das
Dschungelcamp wahrscheinlich ja aber
niemand würde zugeben dass sie wieder
sich die Formate anschauen deshalb ich
bin seit der ersten Stunde dabei ich
habe schon extreme Höhen und Tiefen
mitgenommen ja also man ist sozusagen
eine Künstlerin eine Anführungszeichen
man muss ja sich beim Finanzamt anmelden
man bekommt eine Steuernummer man muss
jedes Mal jedes Jahr nach jedem Projekt
Umsatzsteuer Einkommensteuer wie jeder
andere Mensch auch alles versteuern ja
und ähm ja man ist aber das ist einer
der Geschichte ja und jeder andere Job
auch hat auch dieser Berufe und
Nachteile an dem Tag wo ich das
Interview der Bild-Zeitung gegeben habe
ich hatte wirklich einen schlechten Tag
ja ich hatte was schlechtes gelesen über
mich und da hatte ich so einen Hals
gehabt und ja es ist halt es sind auch
die Schattenseiten und es sind auch
wirklich es ist manchmal die
öfter
öfteren die saubere Pille die man oder
ja Pille schlucken muss man wird immer
belächelt dieser Branche ist ja wirklich
nicht oder reality ist oder influencerin
zu sein ist ja wirklich ein kein
anerkannter Beruf das tut man einfach es
ist eine neue Nische seit 15 Jahren
diese diese Branche hat extrem
zugenommen die letzten 15 Jahren seitdem
ich social Medien so wirklich einfach so
präsent sind ja zu meiner Zeit 98 ich
bin seit 98 im Geschäft seitdem ich
dabei bin gab es diese ganzen Instagram
und Co gar nicht ja ich bin einfach mit
mit einem Format bekannt geworden seit
der ersten Stunde bin ich dabei also
seit 20 Jahren und ja man wird belächelt
es wird nicht angenommen zumindest von
Menschen also auch gesellschaftlich
nicht man sagt immer was ist so ehrlich
ist da was ist das ist Respekt auch für
ihre ganze Branche würden sie sich
selbst als Vorbild bezeichnen ist das
auch etwas was sie von Fans
beispielsweise gespiegelt bekommen
sind also es ist so dass man einerseits
nicht gesellschaftlich anerkannt wird
man denkt was ist das ist doch kein
anerkannter wo viele wissen gar nicht
den Begriff Influenza oder ich bin auch
Gott sei Dank keine in sondern das muss
ich auch an dieser Stelle betonen ja
aber ein reality sah zu sein aber
Schattenseiten ja es hat aber ich möchte
auch nicht undankbar sein ich habe gutes
Geld verdient es ist ein lukratives
Geschäft wenn man nur mit Geld umgehen
kann ja wenn man zwei Projekte im Jahr
hat 200.000 Euro verdient okay was mich
nur stört dass ich mal Einkommensteuer
zahlen muss ja da bleibt nicht mehr viel
übrig aber
hatten Seiten sind ja wenn die wenn die
Auftragslage sich verschlechtert ja wer
ist denn für einen da keiner ja ich habe
gerade eine Rechnung bekommen ich muss
meine
Balkonen müssen gemacht werden da klopfe
ich auch nicht auf der Matte vom
Finanzamt und sage ich muss meine
Einkommensteuer zahlen über 50%
Abdrücken können Sie bitte mal meine
Kosten für den Zahnriemen ein Job der
einen Job ist eine Arbeit ist für die
sie hart arbeiten für diese etwas tun
für andere die blicken damit wenig
Respekt drauf und fragen sich was tut
sie da was machen ich verstehe es
vielleicht auch gar nicht so richtig sie
würden sich vielleicht auch als
Unterhaltungskünstlerin auch um das mal
zu
übersetzen
was nicht in Deutschland so wirklich
irgendwie belächelt wird man sagt
Formate wir können alle englisch
also man macht quasi ich habe mit mit
Quatsch mit einfach Quatsch im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes mein Geld verdienen die
letzten 20 Jahre sie sind ja trotzdem
stolz drauf ich bin den Quatsch ich bin
ich habe Geld verdient wenn man mit Geld
gut umgehen kann anlegen kann kann man
sagen mein Gott ich habe wirklich gutes
Geld verdient ja aber die ganzen
influencer die wie die Pilze aus der
Erde kommen und alle Fame werden wollen
und berühmt werden wollen ich frage mich
Leute macht erstmal kommt erstmal dahin
wo ich heute bin was macht
Karriere ist für sie Katalog auch ein
Vorbild also für mich jetzt nicht aber
ganz allgemein kann ich sagen warum
messen Sie sich an dem was irgendjemand
denkt sie sind offensichtlich
unternehmerisch tätig sie sind
selbstständig sie verdienen mit ihrer
eigenen Leistung Geld sie bieten ein
Produkt alles offensichtlich nachgefragt
wird und als Vertreter der
marktwirtschaftlichen Ordnung als den
ich mich sehe finde ich das erstmal gut
Sie haben recht aber ich mache mir schon
längst keine Gedanken mehr und glauben
Sie mir ich habe so ein dickes Fell
inzwischen aufgebaut ich mache mir keine
Gedanken was was die einzelnen Menschen
denken da würde ich mich ja aufhängen ja
das müsste ich mir den Strick nehmen ich
mache viele Gedanken es ist ja so die es
gibt eine Industrie in Deutschland die
mit dir halt ihre Produkte werben wollen
wäre aus Trash kommt aus dieser Ecke
kommt ist halt nicht seriös genug für
ein Produkt zu werben ja also man
bekommt jetzt nicht
einen Job als Moderatorin oder als als
seriöses man steckt in Deutschland
gerade
Schublade drin und das ist das was mich
nervt vor der Leistung von Katalog auf
jeden Fall also letztlich das was sie
machen ist ja nichts anderes als Werbung
im weiteren Sinne in dem Fall erstmal
sie haben eine Markennamen aufgebaut der
funktioniert in dem Segment und das ist
etwas was er also sowohl fürs politische
als auch letztlich für jede andere
Berufsbranche sind Unternehmensberater
genau wie finden Psychologen relevant
ist dass man
es schafft a den Namen bekannt zu machen
und damit bestimmte Werte zu verbinden
und auch der der Wert Trash TV wird ja
grundsätzlich nachgefragt ja das ist
interessant das Gucken in der Tat Leute
damit werden Werbeeinnahmen verbunden
auch das ganze Thema Instagram Marketing
ja ist ja auch etwas das in der Tat
nachgefragt wird davon leben Menschen
die eben halt damit von ihrer Arbeit
leben und ob ich jetzt ganz praktisch im
übrigen als Unternehmen hingehe und mir
eine Plakat Werbefläche oder
Fernsehwerbung oder sonst was buchen
oder sagen Mensch wollen sie nicht mal
ein Foto machen mit meinem Produkt XYZ
oder mal darüber sprechen dass dieses
oder jenes gut ist ist letztlich auch
nichts anderes also insofern da hat sich
einfach
marktwirtschaftlich ein Angebot
entwickelt für eine Nachfrage und
dementsprechend also kann man nur sagen
aus dieser Runde und das wird auch da
ganz klar als Arbeit als Job anerkannt
auch noch mal ihre Meinung Herr Bonelli
wir haben über Vorbilder gesprochen
früher gab es Vorbilder das waren quasi
Superman Superwoman oder man weiß es
nicht und jetzt haben wir Kader Loth
auch einen Vorbild für viele
gleichzeitig jetzt ja auch gesagt auf
Instagram gibt es natürlich viele ja
einfach den schnellsten die verschieden
sind für mich anschreiben und sagen
durch liebe dich du du verstehst du ich
fühle mich immer geschmeichelt ja aber
ich kenne auch die Tiefen der Branche
die wollen alle beruhigt werden macht
das was ich gemacht habe mal lieber
nicht ich würde sagen ich habe
Einzelhandel ich habe einen
Berufsausbildung in der Tasche Leute ihr
wisst nicht wo ihr in 10 Jahren steht
macht erstmal eure Ausbildung
Berufsausbildung und dann seid ihr
erstmal auf der sicheren Seite weil
diese Branche bringt auch viele
Schattenseiten wo du jahrelang
monatelang nichts verdient und da musst
du gucken da guckst du ganz blöd aus der
Wäsche
also sind das Vorbilder jetzt die die
schnell den Erfolg auf Instagram suchen
wollen dass wir sagen müssen das ist
auch eine Gefahr für viele man sitzen im
Handy dann sagt das ist doch schneller
Erfolg das mache ich jetzt auch mal ich
mache mir Lippenstift ins Gesicht oder
ich weiß es nicht sind sie darin eine
Gefahr aus der Branche die auch Katalog
beschrieben hat influencer oder
zumindest auch junge Frauen die das sein
wollen also zuerst einmal finde ich das
ich glaube es ist wichtig dass es
Menschen gibt die die Menschen also ich
glaube die Leute mögen sich ich habe sie
nicht gekannt muss ich ehrlich sagen
[Gelächter]
die Menschen mögen das menschliche und
offensichtlich bringen sie das rüber sie
sind authentisch sie sind emotional sie
sie also man kann sie nachvollziehen das
glaube ich und keine gescheiten Sätze
sondern einfach von der Lee frei von der
Leber weg also das ist glaube ich
sympathisch und das ist anziehen und ich
glaube das hat eine Funktion in der Welt
wo wo alle eine Maske tragen wo also
jetzt ich meine sondern wo alle ein
Spiel spielen oder alles so tun als wenn
sie souverän und hätten keine Fehler
also das glaube ich ist wichtig für die
Gesellschaft aber natürlich kann man es
übertreiben ich kenne natürlich auch
Fälle die also von von jungen Mädchen so
16 17 18 die dann so hinein kippen und
halt glauben sie machen schnell die
große Kohle und die werden halt alles so
berühmt wie sie und halt die wenigsten
wären das aber das ist in jeder Branche
so ich weiß es gibt viele Unternehmer
kleine Unternehmer die werden halt nie
so groß wie was weiß ich wer auch immer
und genauso ist es beim Fußball und
überall und genauso ist es halt bei
ihnen sie haben es geschafft und viele
werden es nicht schaffen die probieren
sondern es nicht schaffen
aber wenn sie keine Ausbildung haben
also wenn sie halt nur auf Instagram
herhalten die Ausbildung auch Katalog
sagt ich bin Einzelhandelskauffrau bin
froh dass ich das habe wer weiß wo das
Leben noch so hinführt was das Leben
noch für Überraschungen bereitet das
haben sie auf jeden Fall das kann Ihnen
keiner nehmen ganz kurze Pause hier bei
Villach 8
geht es um die Wirtschaft und dann geht
es auch um die Wahl hier in der
Hauptstadt jetzt nämlich am kommenden
Sonntag dass die jetzt wiederholt wird
das haben wir den Mann hier neben mir zu
verdanken und darüber sprechen wir
gleich bis gleich
[Musik]
es waren wirklich viele Verstöße und
peinlichste Pannen damals bei der Wahl
hier in der Hauptstadt der musste man
mit dem Fahrrad noch schauen dass
irgendwo Wahlzettel besorgt werden und
sie sie haben uns jetzt möglich gemacht
das jetzt am Sonntag diese Wahl
wiederholt wird das steht auch immer
lasst es Verfassungsgerichtshof sie
sagen diese Wiederholung ist wichtig für
die Demokratie was man für Sie die
größten pannenhilute und das erwarten
sie jetzt für den Sonntag ihr Thema
vielen Dank also die allergrößte Panne
war sicherlich erstmal dass Leute die
wählen wollten nicht wählen konnten ja
weil ja bekanntermaßen teilweise drei
Stunden die Menschen in den Schlangen
standen aushalten müssen gerade auch
ältere Familie mit Kindern wieder
weggehen muss noch mal wieder kam und
dann erfahren haben auch menschlich
jetzt sind keine Stimmzettel mehr da
jetzt kannst du auch nicht mehr wählen
das war ein ganz dramatisches Problem
ein weiteres war das falsche Stimmzettel
ausgegeben worden vorsätzlich teilweise
wir haben den Friedrichshain Kreuzberg
gehabt das von den Grünen geführte
Wahlamt hat gezielt falsche Stimmzettel
ausgeben lassen den Leuten dann gesagt
tut uns leid habt ihr halt leider
ungültig gewählt wir haben sogenannte
friedhofsstimmen gehabt das heißt
bereits verstorbene bekommen eine
Wahlbenachrichtigung zugeschickt der
Erbe was auch immer vielleicht auch der
Hinterbliebene wäre auch immer öffnet
die Post kann das grundsätzlich
ausfüllen zurückschicken weil du mich
niemand die Unterschriften vergleicht
und dann werden Briefwahlunterlagen
rausgeschickt auch etwa 20.000 und wir
haben die Situation gehabt dass Menschen
Briefwahl beantragt haben dadurch werden
sie automatisch im weder Verzeichnis für
die uhrenwahl gesperrt gehen dann los
stellen fest auf Mensch ich habe leider
immer noch gar keine Post bekommen kann
gar nicht die Briefe machen wollen
Wahllokal wählen und sind dort dann
ebenfalls sehr gesperrt können also gar
nicht werden das bedarf etwa 80 bis
90.000 stimmen also die ungültig
ausgegeben und dementsprechend auch
nicht ungültig eingesetzt werden konnten
und ähnlich erleben wir das jetzt gerade
zumindest in Teilen auch bereits wieder
wir haben das große Thema das
Poststreiks hier in Berlin ja gerade
und ausgerechnet jetzt wo also die Wahl
bevorsteht wo Briefwahlunterlagen
unterwegs sind wird Berlin sowieso schon
eine lange Postleitzahl hat auch noch
zusätzlich bestreicht also insofern
können wir hier erwarten dass das Chaos
nicht viel geringer sein wird fürchte
ich ich bin mir sicher dass es an den
Urnen besser laufen wird aber insgesamt
muss ich sagen trifft auch diese
Vorbereitung nicht ansatzweise dass wir
eigentlich Wahlen organisiert sein
sollten haben sie jetzt auch erlebt ist
ein teilweise Kandidaten auf den
Stimmzetteln aufgetaucht die nicht drauf
gehört hatten es sind Kandidaten von den
Stimmzetteln gestrichen worden die
tatsächlich noch keine Tieren und wir
haben jetzt die absurde Situation dass
Leute die die Parteien gewechselt haben
wir haben es irgendwo bei einem Wechsel
von den Linken zu den Grünen immer noch
auf der Liste der einen Partei stehen
für die auch gewählt werden ganz
automatisch und dann aber der anderen
Fraktion im Parlament angebracht also am
Sonntag ist eventuell wieder für die
Katze hat man vielleicht noch mal
verschieben müssen oder Hoffnung das
habe ich für sehr sehr richtig gehalten
und habe genau das auch tatsächlicher
beantragt beim Landes
auffassungsgerichtshof dem ist man
zunächst nicht gefolgt wir haben ja die
Situation des gleichzeitig jetzt
Kollegen aus FDP linken SPD und Grünen
diese Anfechtung quasi wieder
angefochten haben das liegt jetzt beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht so dass es also
durchaus sein kann dass wir in einigen
Wochen erfahren werden Edge das was am
12.2 als Wahl stattgefunden hat war doch
keine Wahl durfte nicht stattfinden das
gilt wieder das alte Ergebnis in dem
Fall gehe ich allerdings auch dagegen
wieder davor dann gibt es noch den
Europäischen Gerichtshof der darüber
entscheiden müsste also es ist ein
unfassbares Chaos und bitte Aufklärung
des Chaos so dilettantisch wie das hier
leider gelaufen ist auch von Berliner
landesverfassungsgerichtshof das muss
ich an der Stelle mal sagen der über
vieles einfach leider hinweggegangen ist
was vorgetragen wurde sind wir jetzt in
der Situation dass wir das Vertrauen in
den Demokratie meines Erachtens eher
noch mehr beschädigt haben als dass das
ausgeräumt hätten wenn sie das hören was
funktioniert überhaupt noch wir hatten
gestern
sagte hier ganz klar es ist aus seiner
sich nicht mehr viel also von der Bahn
bis zur Bundeswehr was funktioniert
eigentlich noch in Deutschland und jetzt
sind wir hier die Befürchtung für den
Sonntag also viel funktioniert nicht
mehr aber ich glaube bevor ich zu der
Frage kommen vielleicht noch eins zwei
Sätze zu der Wahl selbst erstmal denke
ich dass wir alle an gute danken sollten
dass er das überhaupt auf den Weg
gebracht hat denn ohne Wahlen gibt es
keine Demokratie also Demokratie besteht
nicht nur aus Wahlen aber ohne Wahlen
gibt es keine und ich glaube dass die
ganz weit überwiegende Mehrheit der
Menschen in diesem Land die Demokratie
möchte und wenn wir die möchten dann
müssen wir ein bisschen Mühe uns geben
und da reicht's nicht wenn wir sagen ich
kann es halt ja sondern wir machen doch
diesen ganzen Unsinn nach der Devise wir
können es ja wir können uns ja erlauben
wir können uns ja leisten es können wir
aber eben genau nicht und dass die
Wahlen in Berlin nicht funktionieren ähm
das ist eigentlich nur ein Symptom
Berlin ist generell ich sag mal
typischerweise der negativ Entwicklung
die Deutschland als Land insgesamt
leider nimmt und genommen hat immer ein
paar Jahre voraus es hat die Hauptstadt
zu an sich deswegen ist das spotten über
Berlin zwar wohl weil und ich habe es
auch selber schon verbrochen aber es ist
im Grunde genommen auch mit dem Blick in
den Spiegel für den Rest des Landes und
so viel funktioniert hinter der Tat
nicht mehr Herr Hana hat es ja sehr
schön formuliert das Bundeswehr ist ich
sag mal so zum Thema
Abwehrbereitschaft gegen äußere gefahren
habe ich mal den Scherz gemacht wir
können froh sein dass Liechtenstein
gerade nicht einmarschieren will ja oder
ob es die Wirtschaft ist die ich sag mal
an allen Ecken und Enden vor die Wand
gedrückt wird aber da kommen wir nachher
noch drauf
oder ob es unseren unsere
Abstimmungsprozesse im internationalen
Umfeld sind das im Grunde genommen jedes
Steinchen dass man hier umdreht da
sitzen hässliches Tierchen drunter hat
mir immer das Gefühl und da fragt man
sich natürlich schon woran liegt nach
meiner Meinung liegt daran dass wir eine
negativ Auswahl unserer politischen
Klasse haben darf ich eine Frage stellen
mir Blödheit oder es ist böse sein dass
das nicht funktioniert hat
also ich habe dazu oder also zu dem
Gesamtkomplex im Buch geschrieben mit
dem schönen Untertitel also über Berlin
unsere Hauptstadt ist mit Missmanagement
und organisierter Kriminalität und
insofern das beantwortet eigentlich ist
es ein breites Spektakel sie haben
einerseits das und zum anderen das und
es kann eben die von Ihnen als Bosheit
bezeichnete Eigenschaft dann natürlich
noch mal besonders gedeihen wenn Sie
zusätzlich auf Dummheit trifft und
wechselseitig und insofern haben wir
hier glaube ich in der Tat eine eine
fatale Entwicklung die sich
wechselseitig bedingt und das wird eben
an keiner Stelle durchgerissenes ändert
sich nicht aber wie ist das für sie
Blick aus dem Ausland aus Österreich
wenn Sie das Hören diese Aufzählung was
alles schief lief bei der ersten Wahl
die Befürchtung dass es vielleicht am
Sonntag wieder zu peinlichsten Pannen
kommen könnte was denkt man da über
Deutschland ja weil ich wusste ja schon
von Berliner Flughafen der das war ja
offensichtlich auch ein riesiges
Desaster ich meine wir sind jetzt auch
nicht ohne in Wien geht's auch ab muss
man sagen aber wahrscheinlich nicht auf
dem Niveau oder
blicken sie da auf Deutsch Deutschland
weiß nicht ob so was in den 50er 60er
70er Jahren auch passieren hätte können
und da habe ich natürlich meine These
von den Bauchgefühlen ich glaube dass
wir unsere Bau also das wäre viel zu
viel fühlen und viel zu wenig denken
also das glaube ich ist ein Grundproblem
in unserer Gesellschaft immer mehr also
die Leute kommen zu mir und sagen es
fühlt sich wahr an und dann sage ich
immer aber da müssen sie nachdenken ob
es wahr ist aber nicht so schön
wir werden auch blöder
also das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich von
Ihnen hören aber ich würde nein also wir
sind blöd wenn wir nur mit dem
bauchdenken dann sind wir blöd also wir
sind ein wir sind Menschen also Sigmund
Freud redet von drei Instanzen ich habe
das sozusagen umgearbeitet auf Kopf Herz
und Bauch wir haben Bauchgefühle die
sind wichtig aber das sind in sich sagen
wir mal nicht die intelligente aber dann
brauchen wir den Kopf der denkt darüber
nach ist der Bauch sagt und das Herz
entscheidet aber wenn wir aus dem Bauch
heraus entscheiden dann sind wir dumm
mehr nachdenken mehr eigen Verantwortung
der sind wir ja gerade auch direkt bei
Ihnen im Thema jetzt mitten im Wahlkampf
gibt es natürlich viele Versprechungen
die man machen kostenlosen Nahverkehr
beispielsweise die sagen aber das das
ist genau der falschen Weg dieses Thema
der falsche Weg und zwar einfach
deswegen weil hier wird Wohlstand
erstmal abgeschöpft und dann wird er
umverteilt für alles mögliche und all
diese ganzen politischen Projekte wo
sich Politiker die eigentlich an den
fundamentalen Dingen wie wir gerade
gesehen haben versagen die nehmen sich
jetzt vor die Welt zu verbessern an
allen möglichen Enden sie versprechen
uns kostenlosen Nahverkehr kostenlose
Kitas kostenlos ich weiß was alles und
worum geht's dann letzten Endes wirklich
es geht eigentlich darum dass ein Teil
der Gesellschaft durch Leistung diese
ganzen Dinge erarbeiten muss denn zum
Beispiel Nahverkehr oder Kita wird er
nicht dadurch kostenlos dass der Staat
ist bezahlt sondern es bezahlt ja auch
nicht der Staat sondern jemand anderes
bezahlt ist ich muss es vorher jemandem
wegnehmen ich muss es jemandem wegnehmen
der vorher was geleistet hat
und was rechtfertigt das das
rechtfertigt sich aus dem
Mehrheitsprinzip mehr ist es nicht ja
und wenn ich den Menschen die etwas
leisten etwas wegnehme dann muss ich
letzten Endes auch die die etwas leisten
davon zu überzeugen dass das mit Maß und
Mitte passiert und dieses Maß und diese
Mitte haben wir längst verlassen weil
jeder Wahl Zyklus dazu führt dass die
Politiker um Mehrheiten zu gewinnen mit
anderen Worten um Stimmen zu kaufen und
nichts anderes ist es mehr abschöpfen
müssen ist die Steuerschraube irgendwann
ausgereizt kommt die schuldenschraube
und ist die schuldenschraube irgendwann
ausgereizt kommt die gelddruckschrauber
und diese Zyklus ist ein letztes
politischer Zyklus der führt uns vor die
Wand sie waren Unternehmensberater in
den großen Firmen BCG MC Roland Berger
sagen Sie uns mal drei Punkte wo sie
sagen das können wir uns nicht mehr
leisten das muss weg also wir können uns
nicht mehr leisten ein bürokratieapparat
der sich nur noch mit sich selbst
beschäftigt wenn sie von den 14
Ministerien zehn abschaffen das merkt
kein Mensch
das gilt auch für die 99 Bundesbehörden
da gehe ich jede Wette ein wir können
uns nicht mehr leisten ein sozialapparat
der nicht die Bedürftigen nicht auf die
Bedürftigen hört sondern auf die lauten
also mit anderen Worten der die
Schwachen nicht vor den faulen schützt
das können wir uns auch nicht mehr
leisten und wir können uns nicht mehr
leisten ist Sozialamt der Welt zu sein
wir müssen den Menschen da draußen
helfen aber wir müssen ihnen nicht
dadurch helfen dass wir in jede
Verantwortung abnehmen sondern indem wir
ihnen Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe geben also
mehr Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe sie haben
genickt
gute Einstellung so muss es ja auch sein
weil sonst kriegt man sich hier im Kreis
finde ich ne weniger öffentliche Hand
heißt aber vielleicht auch weniger für
Schulen weniger für Kitas die dann
schlechter ausgestattet sind natürlich
erstmal gut mehr im eigenen Geldbeutel
weil wenn wir das was wir was wir jetzt
machen tun dann ist eben für die
Kernaufgaben des Staates gar kein Geld
mehr da der Staat beschafft bist befasst
sich mit allen möglichen Dingen für ihr
nicht zuständig ist und die Dinge für
dir zuständig ist vernachlässig darüber
und das sind eben Schulen und das ist
die Verteidigungsfähigkeit des Landes
ist das ist Rechtsprechung
Rechtssicherheit und der Gleichnis gibt
kann Aufgaben des Staates die fühlt er
aber gar nicht mehr aus weil jeder
Politiker sich ein Hobby sucht jeder
Politiker sucht sich ein Hobby mit dem
er Karriere macht und dass sie nicht die
Kernaufgaben des Staates die sind
nämlich langweilig und deswegen befährt
man sich lieber mit all den
Randbereichen und Schaufel das Geld in
die Randbereiche in alle möglichen
Bedürfnisse in alle möglichen meine wir
haben 200 gender Lehrstühle in diesem
Land die der Stadt und der Steuerzahler
finanziert ich werde das unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit dass ich auf ganz
neue Höhen kommt also da muss man sich
Tomaten Kopf fassen was finanzieren wir
denn finanzieren wir lesen und schreiben
oder finanzierender Sprache also sie
sagen auch thematisch muss man da
unbedingt denken andere Schwerpunkte
setzen gleichzeitig soziale
Marktwirtschaft hat Deutschland 1 stark
gemacht da liegen auch unsere Kern ja
unsere Kernen Energie würde passt nicht
aber die Energie der Kern des Ganzen
eine gute sehen Sie das ähnlich oder
glauben Sie es gibt so eine Art
Mittelweg die man entgegen könnte wir
sind das richtig formuliert gerade die
soziale Marktwirtschaft um die geht es
nur haben wir in den letzten Jahrzehnten
erlebt dass das was als soziale
Marktwirtschaft mal entstanden ist mit
einem scharfen Löffel ausgehöhlt wurde
und etwas Neues reingepackt wurde was
wir hier immer mehr erleben ist ein
patentalistischer übergriffiger
nanny-staat der glaubt eben alle
Aufgaben übernehmen zu können die
eigentlich private in der Tat deutlich
besser können und das führt eben halt
automatisch welche Aufgaben kommen
nehmen Sie den gesamten Bereich der
Gesundheitsversorgung zum Beispiel ja
wir haben da einen riesigen Bereich bei
den gesetzlichen Krankenversicherungen
der einfach eins zu eins durchläuft an
die Pharmakonzerne ja nichts durch die
Frage ist was brauche ich denn
eigentlich davon wäre es nicht
vielleicht viele intelligenter wenn ich
selbst auch als der
gezwungenermaßen gesetzlich versichert
hatte direkt bei meinem Arzt erfahren
würde was der für die Leistung der mit
der anbietet bekommt was das ganze
kostet eine Idee ist schon Jahrzehnte
alte wird aber nicht umgesetzt warum
wird sie nicht umgesetzt weil unter
anderem auch natürlich ein großes
Interesse der nach wie vor hoch
profitablen Pharmaunternehmen besteht
beispielsweise als eine Thema dass sie
sehen Herr Kerl was sind denn ihre
Befürchtungen wenn da jetzt nicht in
Ihrem Sinne gegengesteuert wird na gut
wir haben ja schon im Grunde genommen
des Desaster ordentlich angehört wir
haben jetzt 10% Inflation was bedeutet
das bei einem Geldvermögen der deutschen
von 7 Billionen pro Jahr 700 Milliarden
sich in Luft auflösen an Kaufkraft das
ist Alter in zehn Jahren
programmiert wird durch die Inflation in
großen Stil da werden Ersparnisse in
ungeheuriger Menge aufgebraucht die
Leute merken es nur noch nicht weil das
sind Dinge die sie zurückgelegt haben
die sie jetzt noch gar nicht ausgegeben
dass sie Einkommen schon schrumpft ist
haben sie mitbekommen wir haben aber
viel tiefer gehendes Problem wir haben
eine Zerstörung der Lieferketten wir
haben eine Beschädigung der
industriellen Basis unseres Landes durch
eine falsche Energiepolitik deren Folgen
wir noch überhaupt nicht abschätzen
können welchen Anteil haben auch die
Manager daran viele Unternehmen waren
jetzt abgehen ins Ausland viele der
Wirtschaften aber auch nur noch auf die
Rendite hin haben keine langfristigen
Ziele mehr es geht nur um eine
schnellere Rendite die Ziele muss man
erreichen aber wirklich langfristig wird
nicht gedacht muss man da nicht auch
gesagt haben widerspreche ich Manager
sollen auf Rendite hin wirtschaften und
das sollten natürlich machen die Fehler
aber der Markt bestraft die in der Regel
sofort es sei denn sie hängen am
staatstropfen und da liegt nämlich im
Pfeffer Großteil unserer Konzerne hat
sich nämlich so organisiert wieder stark
organisiert ist die Konzerne haben durch
das Aktienrecht dass wir uns gegeben
haben eine Entkoppelung von Eigentum und
Management und diese Entkopplung von
Eigentum und Management führt dazu das
große Konzerne auf die große Bürokratie
funktioniert und nicht mehr wie
Unternehmen die eigentlichen Unternehmen
in diesem Land sind nicht die großen
Konzerne sondern der Mittelstand und
Chef eines Konzerns werden sie nicht
dadurch dass sie unternehmerisch ticken
sondern dass sie keine Fehler machen mit
anderen Worten dass sie Risiken
vermeiden mit anderen Worten sind nicht
unternehmerisch tätig sind und solche
Konzerne die orientieren sich dann eben
auch nicht mehr an den Bedürfnissen ihre
Kunden sondern die orientieren sich an
der Lobbyarbeit beim hat und sehen zu
dass sie den Staat dazu bringen
irgendwelche Dinge zu machen die ihnen
dann zum Vorteil gereicht das heißt die
Konzerne sind sicher nicht unsere
Rettung der Mittelstand ist unsere
Rettung aber den müssen wir befreien von
den von der Knechtschaft der
Überregulierung schauen Sie wenn Sie zum
Beispiel so was wie das dsgvo nehmen
also dieses ganze Datenschutz Thema zu
berechtigt des Anliegen des
Datenschutzes ist aber man hat dadurch
adressiert dass man eine bürokratische
Glocke über den Mittelstand gestillt hat
besonders leidet immer wieder auch immer
wieder Thema hier in der Sendung Thema
dass wir auf jeden Fall auch noch mal
vertiefen müssen ich danke ganz herzlich
an meine Gäste vielen Dank für diese
Diskussion ich danke natürlich auch
ihnen fürs zuschauen hier bei 8:15 Uhr
[Musik]